a decorated former soldier who fought
for Britain now fighting for his freedom
after being accused by police in Dubai
of selling drugs
Andrew Neal denies the charge but has
spent more than four months in detention
his father Morris issued this statement
to Sky News through a representative the
stress and worry about Andy over these
past four and a half months frankly
eclipses whatever anxiety we felt when
he was serving in conflict zones
overseas over all the years if anything
happened to him then we know it was for
a cause in service to our country he's
suffering now and he's facing danger in
hardships for absolutely no reason
whatsoever mr. Neal his wife and their
two young children have lived in Dubai
since 2015 the former army dog handler
ran a dog training business until police
turned up at his apartment in October
and arrested him the group representing
his family say he then unwittingly
signed a confession despite saying he
was innocent the detained in Dubai group
say he remains behind bars even though
his alleged accuser apparently retracted
his statement mr. Neal who spent 24
years in the Army and received medals
for service in Iraq Afghanistan and
elsewhere is just the latest in a line
of British citizens to end up detained
in the United Arab Emirates the Foreign
Office says it's providing him with
assistance and is in touch with his
family diplomats are also supporting a
British Sudanese football fan who's in
detention and the Foreign Office had to
help academic matthew hedges who was
only freed following a pardon after he
says he was forced to confess to being
an mi6 officer his lawyer when asked
about mr. Neal's case says the UAE
system doesn't have human rights
protections and the rule of law at its
core
he's therefore without any assistance
internally he needs the intervention of
the international community of the UK
government to come to his aid otherwise
it's going to be a very lonely
the Dubai authorities have yet to
respond to questions about mr. Neal's
case the former soldier who's recovering
from post-traumatic stress disorder
could be transferred to Abu Dhabi if
he's not released his family is
appealing to Foreign Secretary Jeremy
Hunt to help him return home Debra
Haines Sky News